looking at the impacts of climate change
on our cities now the past few weeks
have demonstrated that our planet is in
crisis with extreme weather events
affecting countries around the world now
last week storm ida caused devastation
in parts of the united states including
flash flooding in new york now jerome
that's where you are now and i
understand that new york subway flooded
three times this summer i mean that's
evidence that america is just not
equipped to deal with extreme weather
events is it so you're a white house
advisor what are you telling president
biden to do about it
absolutely this is a
a clear example of how america doesn't
have enough investment in infrastructure
to protect us from the climate crisis
and the short-term answer to make sure
that we are
are not long-term impacted by hurricane
irma is to get immediate assistance to
those that are impacted the long-term
answer is to create a civilian climate
corps in america to employ people that
will go door to door and make sure
people have access to um climate justice
um resources and make sure that they're
able to be rescued and employed after
this so there's so many things we need
to do but not enough is being done right
now and what about the uk mariam i'm
actually going to take a look at
something that the climate change
committee said in a report this year
their advisors to the government of
course they have said the uk doesn't yet
have a vision for successful adaptation
to climate change so maraming looks like
we're not terribly well prepared here
either what do you think
absolutely i mean in that report they
looked at 34 priority areas i believe
and we haven't made significant progress
on any of them and so i think that
adaptation is not something that you
know people who are not immersed in the
climate conversation every day maybe
have thought about but it is something
that our governments have known we need
to do and action has been has been short
you know has been slow and now might be
too late for some people well yes and
jerome why do you think this is i've
noticed there have been calls this week
to make sure that adaptation that is
things like building flood defenses and
adapting to a changing climate
should have equal priority at cop26 at
the u.n climate summit um at the moment
there's been a lot of talk about getting
emissions down but do you think that
that's come at the expense of a focus on
adaptation
well i think that the conversation
should be both and it should be one
focusing on future emissions but also
making sure that we're holding them
accountable by seeing real investment
year over year we need to make sure that
every every year we're seeing actual
tangible change and not pretty words
that often fall empty in communities
like how we're seeing in
new york city right now are reeling from
because of the empty promises that
happen in the 2010s
so transparency and holding people to
account mariam also is there an issue of
of money here there's only a finite
amount finite amount of money and
governments around the world have spent
billions trying to meet against against
mitigate against covid and is there a
risk if you spend loads of money on
adaptation it takes money away from some
of those
future technologies ways of of trying to
get emissions down
i mean i agree with jeremy this is a
both and you're not going to be able to
solve this problem if you only look at
adaptation or you only look at reduction
in emissions and there are some
solutions that amazingly will help us do
both so i think there's some real space
here to be you know innovative and to
think about things like you know
insulating our homes help us protect us
against extreme weather but it also
helps reduce our energy consumption and
these things can be really effective
and jerome i'm just really interested to
think
to hear what you think about public
opinion in the states they've been it's
been a terrible summer for america in
terms of heat waves wildfires floods do
you think that's changing people's minds
on climate change
um well even though i am a white house
advisor i was a climate activist
beforehand i climate strike for over 100
weeks in front of the white house and i
understand that right now the awareness
is not there the american media is is
sadly not like sky news where you guys
break down the climate crisis our news
is very much just talking about the
hurricane but not talking about the
underlying issue that is the climate
crisis so i think that even though we
have seen a rise in so much natural
disasters from california to florida to
louisiana and now new york city people
are not tying them together and
understanding the broader system of
climate change that is continuing to
stabilize our communities
you